welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and it looks like we just got a new
teaser for the flash movie during dc
fandom it's expected to be an adaptation
of the flashpoint paradox storyline
following ezra miller's barry allen
after the events of zack snyder's
justice league we're not really sure yet
but it is gonna be a movie that ties in
the dc multiverse with characters like
michael keaton batman returning ben
affleck batman returning i'm gonna react
to this teaser just give my initial
thoughts hopefully we see some cool
stuff in it and explain everything you
need to know coming out of zack snyder's
justice league the snyder cut that came
out earlier this year because that set
up this movie in a big way i'm gonna try
to react to this quickly because we also
have some stuff for the robert pattinson
batman movie coming out later i'll also
be breaking all that down but first the
flashpoint movie here we
go
tell me something
central city you can go
anywhere you want right is that keaton's
voice
any timeline
[Music]
no that might just be flash
why do you want to stay
you changed the future
and you changed the path oh my god
ah
yes he's in it
i knew it was coming but it looks
awesome
who wait was that a second ezra
that looked like sasha kaya he's playing
oh my god
so they're having
oh my god
just show us the damn batmobile oh my
god wow okay they are actually doing
flashpoint this is super super exciting
and they're doing it in some ways that i
totally did not expect so flashpoint was
an event in the dc comics that came out
about 10 years ago in which barry allen
uses the cosmic treadmill to basically
build up enough energy where he can go
back in time and he does so to try to
save his mother nora allen who we know
his father henry allen was framed for
killing but we find out through some
complicated timeline mechanics that the
death was actually caused by reverse
flash one of these complicated
predestined versions of time travel
where barry allen's act of time travel
ended up creating this virtuality where
reverse flash would exist and kill nora
allen and frame his father for doing so
but throughout the events of the
flashpoint paradox barry allen ends up
going into a flashpoint timeline where
instead of thomas wayne being killed
bruce wayne was killed and thomas wayne
as a green father ends up becoming
batman in that universe it's also kind
of like a post-apocalyptic circumstance
where the atlanteans have gone to war
against the amazonians a lot of the
earth has been flooded and storyline
ends with all these universes being kind
of converged into one that's what was
called the new 52 in the dc comics there
was a really sweet multiversal letter
exchange between thomas wayne and bruce
wayne it's just one of the sweetest
endings ever now while i'm working to
try to figure all this stuff out i don't
know about you but i like to put on some
music or some podcasts and the app that
i've been using to do all that is amazon
music amazon music is great it has more
than 10 million free podcast episodes to
listen to you can listen to the
hilarious podcast smartless ad free and
one week before everyone else or check
out the breathtaking true crime podcast
dr death miracle man available two weeks
early on amazon music amazon music has
thousands of music stations and top
playlists to stream for free no credit
card required no matter what you're
listening to you can go hands-free with
alexa several of us on the new rockstars
team are using amazon music all the time
off-screen producer zack listens to his
curated playlists of 90s metal on his
phone while exercising i like to play
some classical music while i am working
i put on like a relaxing classical
that's a good one to have on i am
finding some easter eggs i am finding
some easter eggs that is a stretch that
is a stretch oh but that one's legit
that one's legit i cannot defend that
and amazon music unlimited offers music
on demand and ad-free you get unlimited
access to over 75 million songs and
podcasts music videos and more with
amazon music unlimited you can listen to
any song anywhere offline and with
unlimited skips and for a limited time
new customers can try amazon music
unlimited free for 30 days no credit
card required so go to amazon.com
rockstars renews automatically cancel
time terms apply now coming out of zack
snyder's justice league in his
director's cut he ended up adding a
bunch to it to make it its whole
original film and among the things he
added were some specific choice dialogue
from henry allen and barry allen there
was a line where henry allen says i
don't want to see you running in place
in central city running place a nod to
the cosmic treadmill and the moment
where they resurrect superman barry
allen says hey look something bad
happens when i approach the speed of
light crazy things happen to time and
the moment where he tries to sync up
with the mother box hitting the water he
ends up not timing it perfectly so he
has to kind of reverse the time and when
he does that cyborg gets his vision of
how all these horrible things are going
to happen in the future dark side
ravages earth lois gets burned in the
bat cave superman goes crazy enacting
the nightmare scenario that batman
foresaw and batman v superman and then
later in the final act of the snyder cut
barry ends up reversing time again to
prevent the unity which cyborg and
superman were initially failing at
preventing but by reversing time barry
stops all that from happening but some
elements of cyborg's first scene future
remain in place because we know from the
end of the movie there's this whole
nightmare epilogue right where wonder
woman is dead aquaman is dead presumably
lois lane is dead as well because
superman's still really pissed off at
all of them and darkseid has been
successful at using his armada to
conquer the planet but basically the
implication of all these little changes
is that barry allen has the ability to
reverse time by running so fast close to
the speed of light and that is a setup
now for this new movie coming out later
in 2022 but instead of billy crudup as
henry allen ron livingston is replacing
him iris west is coming back from the
snyder cut and we learned last year that
not only is ben affleck returning as his
version of batman from the snyder
version of the films michael keaton is
coming back from the original tim burton
batman films and now knowing all that
starts to contextualize what we see in
this trailer a central city taxi cab
pulls up to this mansion we may be
looking at wayne manor here but there
are two young men who get out of it and
at the end of the trailer we see that
there is not only ezra miller playing
barry allen ezra miller is also playing
a second version of himself with a
slightly altered costume now i'm purely
speculating here but the movie might
actually be having ezra miller also be
playing reverse flash which would be a
really bold kind of weird move because
reverse flash is supposed to look and
sound pretty different but they may be
saying that he's just a kind of variant
of barry allen as opposed to something
completely different the voice we heard
throughout the trailer was the voice of
michael keaton asking him all these
questions if you can go anywhere you
want any timeline in the universe why
would you stay to fight to save this one
so what is this universe is he talking
about the dc universe that he came from
the one that the snyder cut took place
in the one that definitely needed to be
saved at the end of the snyder cut there
was a dialogue between batman and the
joker in which it was implied that
batman had gone through countless
timeline resets to try to fix the ending
of that world but had failed up until
that point until it looked like he was
about to form a truce with the joker
perhaps leveraging the life of harley
quinn to spare the life of lois lane or
are we talking about some kind of
flashpoint universe that barry allen
wants to fight to save a flashpoint
universe that might show michael keaton
as an older bruce wayne implying that
the tim burton universe is just some
kind of altered elseworld timeline and
michael keaton bruce wayne is like what
was wrong with this universe why do you
need to save this one or maybe we're
gonna see some distant future of the tim
burton michael keaton universe one that
has devolved into chaos and madness
something similar to the
post-apocalyptic flashpoint universe
from the comics but make no mistake we
are in the bat cave here that is the
waterfall that's a specific michael
keaton cowl it's just brilliant how just
that silhouette is enough to get us
excited now there's another cryptic shot
of what looks like the top part of a
batman cowl on the ground with blood
spattered and we know from the snyder
cut that superman had a similar cow that
he's just holding up as he was looking
for batman are we gonna see elements of
that same nightmare future are we gonna
see endless deaths of the ben affleck
batman part of this post-apocalyptic
future that barry allen's trying to
prevent now it seems like there are two
different versions of the flash suit
that we see in this teaser there's the
super techno organic one with the
pronounced abs kind of the form-fitting
version that has these tron energy
glowing lines coming out of it but
there's also more of a diy version with
yellow lightning bolts spray painted on
it that i assume is going to be the
secondary ezra miller that we see could
just be a variant of barry allen or the
origin of the reverse flash character in
this film now if you're curious about
this ring with the flash logo on it that
was made by barry allen forging his
parents wedding rings together and it's
compatible it kind of locks into his
suit so based on this teaser i think the
general scope of the movie is going to
be barry allen is going to build on what
he'd learned about his abilities to
reverse time from the snyder cut events
in order to try to go back to the day of
his mother's murder and prove his
father's innocence and also just save
his mother's life but by doing so he's
going to discover that the events around
his mother's death are far more
complicated than he realized wasn't just
a random person who murdered his mom it
was reverse flash who's trying to
destroy his life so he's gonna double
down and try to reverse past that and by
doing so gonna tap into some alternate
dc timelines which in the movie is going
to be him stumbling into other cinematic
universes within the dc multiverse one
of them being the michael keaton
universe as perhaps the most experienced
batman that he can find in the
multiverse and this batman is gonna be
kind of a mentor figure to him and i
really think that could just be the
beginning of the different dc titles
that this movie crosses over into i
think it's gonna be a pretty insane
crossover we already know that he
crossed over the cw universe and that
christ of infinite earth storyline at
the beginning of 2019 and i have a
feeling this movie's gonna try to end
the same way that the comic flashpoint
did by kind of setting the new rules
going forward for dc films that you
could have different co-existing else
worlds stories like the next aquaman
shazam and black atom films but also
this robert pattinson batman universe
stories that don't have to be connected
but they all kind of exist in this
multiverse let me know what you most
loved about this teaser how do you feel
about the possible changes going on with
the reverse flash do you think ezra
miller's alternate character is gonna be
reverse flash is it just some other
variant of barry allen who he's teaming
up with we'll be talking about this
movie a lot more when an official
trailer drops to give us more context of
what the story is gonna be but if you
haven't already subscribe to rockstars
follow me at eavos check out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
and stay tuned for our further coverage
of the robber patterns in batman trailer
we're so excited thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you